Continental Tire coaches corner and he's
Herm Edwards Arizona State head coach
I'm joining us on the program
how are you herm I am rooting my tail
off where are you right now I'm in used
to me the house visit last night and
great family you know I enjoy I I'm
enjoying it I really am I don't have a
lot of fun how strange is this that if I
would have said last year you're gonna
be coaching and you're gonna be coaching
in college what would you say and I've
had possibilities before there's been
opportunities but it was never the right
fit for me
this one kind of got me energy going and
you know it goes back into you know I've
coached that Under Armour all-american
game for the last 18 Mariucci coaches
one side of it I coach the other side of
it you know and you have that meet with
all these five eight players that before
they commit to colleges obviously our
first class was my first class was
Jameson Amari Cooper in those guys you
know that got me excited and toward the
end of the week every year players are
said coach you want to go back to
coaching right opportunity comes about
maybe we'll see him this one kind of
took place and I'm on a roll I'm making
home visits
I couldn't you bought a sports car for
this midlife crisis instead of coaching
job or do you already have the sports
car no you know Tony you you're with
Tony on Sunday and he was excited you
know this is my passion man you never
stop coaching even on television you're
always coaching analyzing things and I
want to be back on the grass I do and
you know I just love the ability to
coach these young men and maybe make a
difference in their life and try to win
a bunch of football games by the way
that's important as well
so I'm ready man I'm excited I really
really am well let me talk you about the
NFL yesterday I know you're still
watching that with the Eagles without
Carson Wentz you know so if we were
gonna rank the top teams in the NFC
right now if if we know that whence is
not going to
the rest of the season how big a drop to
the Eagles take in your opinion they
take a look they become then they become
Minnesota you know strong defense run
the fall run the football they become a
Minnesota team that they're there
they're right there with Minnesota I
thought they were a little bit above
Minnesota cuz a quarterback obviously
winces it's probably a better player
than King so you know that's where they
had the edge defensively
you know Minnesota is one of the better
defenses of football that they ran up
against the Carolina team that obviously
you know it's tough to be but I would
put them level with them now when you
lose the quarterback because you got you
playing with the backup guy because
you're different I mean you're not going
to throw you know what good kid what
about 30 touchdown passes you know I
mean he's you know he's talking about
being the MVP I mean now you know he's
trying to beat out Captain America up
there in New England but he was the
runner going and going into this week is
it a two-team race in the AFC with the
Steelers and Patriots yeah it's bird
there's a team that you know going to
their training camp you know this this
year they were building their defense to
to match up with Pittsburgh
excuse me the New England now the
problem is we saw yesterday that jay-z
er guy is he's a guy that really he can
erase a lot of mistakes because of his
speed and his instincts he's not in
there they're different now different
he's a difference maker you know he's a
game changer he's a problem solver for
you on defense and that's a little bit
of a problem right now yeah I'm trying
to figure out though with I know that
the Steelers they're kind of
unpredictable they're unpredictably good
great I sort of know what I get with the
Patriots I'm not quite sure it feels
like the ceiling can be a little higher
with the Steelers but that cellar can be
a little bit lower with the Steelers you
make a great point Dan and I think it's
you know they're a team that and this is
what been kind of got little sideways
what are you saying well you know the
locker room has changed
different mindset for players and he
struggles with that a little bit you
know in the fact that they are up and
down your emotional team they're a
little bit immature but here's here's
what they got they got two of the best
players in football yeah
the runner and the wide receiver and at
any moment they wouldn't a game for you
coach they'd just win it you know they
they they like age they they they can
win the game and it too big so even when
they play these days they know look real
good you're struggling when you got to
elite players I'm talk about two of the
best players in football the runner and
the wide receiver and they did that last
night we're talking to her mad words
Arizona State's new head football coach
joining us Continental Tire Coach's
Corner you got to save your voice
because when you're working in TV you
could you can ramp up firm but now
you're giving these pitches sales
pitches in living rooms around the
country you got to pace yourself with
the voice I can hear it herm I can hear
it oh look I've been on the phone so
you'll get this you'll get this story
because you work there so I was in
Bristol all week because I committed to
work that week out form so at night when
I got off television I'm on the phone
for like two hours and I'm call the
recruits I've been talking ever since
and if mom offers you food you got to
eat it too so you might pile on 25
pounds here this is why I'm nervous
one kid told me of making houses because
what do you like I said whatever your
mom puts on it in front of me I mean I
had a good meal last night was pretty
good it was really good I got this more
worked out there at 4:30 so I'm okay
well good luck keep the energy keep the
enthusiasm and I'm glad you're having
fun I am sir thank you
that's her med where it's the head Ball
Coach Arizona State Sun Devils there
that's Continental Tire coaches corner
with her Edwards if you would have said
who's more likely to be coaching next
year if I said Jon Gruden or her
Edwards I would have said Jon Gruden not
to say that Jon Gruden won't be but herm
that was his surprise I thought if he
took a job it might be it as an
assistant maybe in the NFL but you're
trying to win press conferences you're
trying to get publicity you could have
brought in somebody who was more
qualified to be a head coach but herm is
bringing in a different type of element
there you know he Arizona State doesn't
have an image and herm is coming in
there with something he's got experience
he's been watching he's coached in the
NFL played in the NFL and they'll
definitely they'll lead the league in
enthusiasm that's sure that's for sure
Continental Tire from Sunday rain to
snow and everything in between
Continental Tire has engineered a tire
for what you do extraordinary
performance and reliability putting
confidence into driving for more
information location of a dealer near
you visit cut entire Continental Tire
for what you do for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]